hey i'm ryan and i am Jerry today we're
gonna hang out and we're gonna talk
about what it's like to be in the friend
zone I've definitely been a friend zone
before girls are interesting to me
because girls always say the same thing
to me it was like Orion you're so funny
and you're sweet and I feel like I can
be open and honest with you and that's
why we should just be friends isn't that
kind of a lame excuse isn't that what
you wanted a boyfriend to be funny and
Sweden you feel like you can be open and
honest but apparently it's not good
enough well because they like you have
to build that thing over to it's like
you can't lead with that you have to
develop that first start out with like
oh we're making jokes yeah and then you
know it slowly gets deeper I think I can
learn a thing or two from you as
possible you can't go looking for it it
always seems like things come together
when you stop looking for that like your
car keys do you everything kind of links
back to the cars are key life is a BAM
and a fork are the car keys is the best
example of life yeah because they're
always like you know isn't that true
you're always like looking for your car
keys the second you give up they appear
right in front of you your life is
hidden between your couch cushions I've
been trying to get girls you know lately
and because i recently got out of a long
relationship when you're in the
launching relationship and you're like
out of it you know the first reaction is
like you know what now is my time to be
single but no girls want to mingle with
this single all a like romantic
relationship is is a really good
friendship plus some other things
basically I think that's just coding for
I'm not attracted to you that way but I
still like all those things about you
it's just kind of hurts my feelings a
little bit yeah it's just kind of a
bummer you know cuz I've been really
horny lately I've recently started doing
a webcam live sex chat stuff oh yeah
that's exciting do there's some of the
hottest girls in there and they always
say the same [ __ ] hey baby it'sit's to
bees hey bebe and then you know they're
always like oh you're cute dude I'm so
horny for you but the first [ __ ] she do
anything can't even get naked waste of
money 299
I got friendzoned buy a webcam girl can
you believe that [ __ ] Orion you just
know what to say on the Internet yeah
even on the web where you're paying for
a girl to get nude for you she's like I
don't feel it i just want to be friends
with you maybe you will beat all the
other guys on that website like you know
cuz i imagine that it's the same thing
as like stripper syndrome where it's
like I've been talking this go at it and
we actually have a bun we should meet
and be actual real people friends but
maybe you can actually get there through
that do thou be so cool because some of
these girls are really hot I'm thinking
of starting on my own life sex chat
webcam series on that channel because I
have fun this [ __ ] you taught you to I
was curious I was like his there's guys
who do it girls they got a masturbate
like to play along just turn off but I
feel like a guy if someone pays for a
private chat they kind of like orgasm
every time I'm assuming for them so just
hot jerking off it's like yeah how much
she meant can one guy have I imagine it
yeah I can see how it would be much
harder for a male model to do that
because you know the mechanics are
different and you actually have to
sustain things yeah you gotta keep it up
all day that's a woman she just has to
touch herself she's a Lube or something
you know it's a budget yeah you you have
to be at least vaguely authentic you
know man you're not a bad-looking guy
really yeah you're pretty good looking
oh thank you I recently admitted on
bisexual and I think if I was the date a
guy I would probably do you really yeah
i mean nice you're funny you're charming
and very is very funny you say later
you're a really sweet guy you're a sweet
guy dude this is why we would be perfect
together because we understand each
other this is true that at the same time
it's almost like I mean you know it's
like we've grown up together that is
true and one day my brother my brother
that's why it it would be good though
man like honestly guys don't you think
it would be good
it's so much easier for a woman than it
is to me a man just in general I think
in general being alone is easier yeah I
think being a woman's lottie's
especially to get guys I don't ever
really hear of a girl ending up in the
friend zone with a guy I rarely hear a
guy be like you know what we can't have
sex unless unless he's like really
turned off by her appearance like if
she's like really ugly or something rube
just got real quiet yeah cuz I spoke the
truth that's what happens Oh once you
comment below and tell me how to get out
of the [ __ ] friend zone